la situación
es normal que la comunidad internacional
no tenga apoyos porque nadie se ha
creído la propaganda falsa que han
estado es el lavado de imagen que han
hecho los talibanes y nadie se ha
querido ellos manejan perfectamente las
redes sociales
el public diplomacy etcétera pero sin
embargo por suerte nadie se ha creído
ese lavado de imagen yo creo que ahora
la situación es va a ser absolutamente
guerra civil va a ser de
ajuste de cuentas se puede incluso
hablar yo no yo no descarto un genocidio
de tayikos y minas y minorías étnicas
que no son pasteles ni y que sean suníes
extra tanto genocidio étnico como
genocidio religioso también se van a
hacer a rendir cuentas con todos los
todos los afganos que no han formado
parte de las fuerzas y cuerpos de
seguridad del estado tanto policías como
militares y que han colaborado como
también traductores fixer
en las instalaciones de las de los
campos de las bases aéreas como la de
edad o kabul el nivel y embajadas
etcétera entonces eso va a haber un
ajuste de cuentas como vimos en los
balcanes y esto quiere decir que también
para poner en el ojo del huracán
a todas las mujeres que durante 20 años
pues han estado estudiando en
universidades han formado
no han querido llevar el burka y el
niqab y entonces pues
pinta muy feo además hay otra cosa
en afganistán se están juntando tres
suites tres filiales importantes en las
que puede enfrentarse más aún ahora que
los talibanes se han hecho con grandes
por piezas de artillería aviones
helicópteros munición etcétera los del
isap y de eeuu que han dejado atrás
porque no se han podido llevar del país
y entonces yo creo que va a haber un
enfrentamiento entre los afganos que
aunque que han participado para las
ocupadas para y xavi para eeuu que es
sálvese quien pueda luego los tres
corazones y escape que es la versión en
en afganistán más luego ha alcanzado
además de éxitos y por desgracia hay que
juntar las milicias de los warning
fighters los centros los milicianos que
ha trabajado en en irak y siria y que
han y que se han replegado sin duda
corre muchísimo peligro ahora perdón que
la interrumpa es que nos queda poco
tiempo pero no quisiera dejar de hacerle
otra pregunta no porque 20 años de
guerra dejan a un talibán que parece más
fortalecido incluso mejor armado que
hace dos décadas no esto se pudo ver en
imágenes que trascendieron en las
últimas horas como explica usted esto
pues es haber duras entradas entre el
ejército las fuerzas y cuerpos de
seguridad del estado de afganistán
durante 20 durante 20 años han sido
después de la guerra de 2 dorm y 15 han
sido
entrenados por los mejores los mejores
militares del mundo todos los que han
formado parte de la colección de esa
entonces saben de estrategia examen de
táctica saben utilizar el armamento que
ha dejado allí y que ha dejado eeuu y
entonces tiene un arsenal increíble que
pasa que ustedes puede decir pero entre
ellos estos militares que han luchado y
casi entrenados con las mejores fuerzas
militares del mundo como puede ser ahora
se pongan de parte de los talibanes pues
esto es un poco saber saberse que puedas
decir o te unes a mí o me matas y luego
por otro parte no podemos descartar que
dentro de los talibán dentro de las farc
cuerpos y fuerzas de la seguridad del
estado habían muchos infiltrados
talibanes con lo cual entre ellos se han
se han organizado y por eso ha sido esta
es la razón por la que ha caído tan tan
rápido en kabul y la granja y 35
capitales de provincias de afganistán
porque dentro del transporte así un
cuerpo de seguridad del estado
entrenador expulsado había muchos
talibanes y encontraron